welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you too
much information about how marvel
sorcerer supreme is actually
supremely negligent information that we
are going to use
to sue doctor strange for malpractice
you've been served
oh you're a jerk i'm eric boss with me
is tommy bechtold how you doing man i'm
feeling good i'm ready for justice to be
served
and if we can't do it we're getting
seleno and barnes in here to figure this
all out
yeah uh strange has been getting away
with too much strange behavior for too
long
and you know what his day of reckoning
has arrived we're bringing the hands
right and we've been wanting to do this
episode because
a couple of months back you may remember
philip molina and i put avengers in-game
on trial
we prosecuted it with all those uh
cinema sins accusations
philip did his darndest to defend this
movie's plot holes
but really if you think about it more
than most dr steven strange
was one of the most able characters in
those two movies
and he made some of the most bizarre
chess move choices
that we don't fully understand if you're
one of those litigious uh phone book
[ __ ] out there looking for someone
to hang charges on uh
tony and natasha they're dead caps
retired
thor star-lord they're off world hulk
isn't a sling no jury is going to
convict a guy in a sling
steven strange is the defendant that you
want to list at the top of that lawsuit
right and ant-man is poor so there's no
money to get from him
that's totally inaccurate no money there
stephen strange
some some attorney got a look at steven
trained his watch collection they're
like hmm
that's right all right
now as we've said before philip has
taken a break this summer from new
rockstar's videos
and uh but just to be clear he keeps
dressing me up so i can act out his
theories he shaves me
everywhere hey
cut that feet
why did we put a camera in there was a
that was our bed
oh right we put a camera in there for
sexy stuff that's right
well that was for the fun stuff but you
know life is all about the good and bad
you take it
good and you take it it was it was a
calculated risk but hey
either way all of you watching see sees
he's fine
he's totally okay to some people that
was the sexy stuff
and there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with it
all right uh this time we're gonna take
stephen strange to trial tommy's gonna
list the charges as our
judge i will be defending the defendant
stephen strange all right so
here's what we were trying to figure out
is doctor strange guilty of negligence
should he have done more and has he
doomed us all
oh that's a difficult challenge well
let's start with
um the legal definition of negligence
neither of us
are lawyers but we know how to wikipedia
things
and negligence is defined as a failure
to behave with the type of care that
someone of ordinary prudence would have
exercised under the same circumstances
the behavior usually consists of actions
but can also consist
of omissions when there is some duty to
act
for example a duty to help victims of
one's previous conduct
so as we uh weigh these uh negligence
charges we're gonna
apply a rule to ourselves it's easy to
say everything strange did an infinity
war in game was all according to
that one victory destiny out of the 14
million 605 alternate
plans that he reviewed but we're gonna
throw that defense out the window
just because it's impossible to prove
and it wouldn't hold up in court it'd be
like saying um
not wearing a mask and coughing on your
groceries is part of the plan from my
visions
[Laughter]
don't throw me in jail i'll allow it
overruled
sustained you're out of line
now the judge is being thrown in jail
i'm holding myself a contempt
um so while we could just use dr
strange's plan to justify all these
things
i'm gonna i'm gonna take the harder
route uh i will propose that my client
had fully valid reasons for each and
every one of his actions
and his inactions interesting all right
well then ladies and gentlemen
this is the people of the mcu in
association with the other mcu that's
man children united
who think they live in this world versus
dr stephen strange
md and sorcerer supreme we will now
proceed with the charges
okay the first charges uh of which there
are many as levied by mezzo jd
on discord why didn't strange use the
time stone to put thanos
in a time loop and then rewind his
attacks or just freeze him
mesojd i assume that jd stands for juris
doctorate so i'm going to take this very
seriously
it's fair to ask this question because
yeah strange i would say did
exercise ordinary prudence with the time
stone plenty of other times like with
dormammu with kaiselius
in hong kong to reassemble the
destruction there if he could rewind a
[ __ ] apple
couldn't he rewind the bites that thanos
took out of tony stark's gut
uh fair fair fair fare but here's why
strange is innocent
uh ladies and gentlemen the jury we have
to assume that thanos possessing
the four infinity stones in the battle
of titan the power stones based on
reality stone soul stone
would make him at least a bit resistant
to the effects of one infinity stone
the time stone these stones are
presented to be of
equal power even though they have
different effects it's not like one
infinity stone even though it's a time
stone can trump four other infinity
stones that control reality
and spatial power and we saw thanos use
those four stones against strange in
different ways he
used the soul stone against him that
must have freaked strange the [ __ ]
out so he must have assumed from that
that thanos could have broken through
any time loop that he put on him it was
also more important to strange to keep
the time stone hidden during the battle
that was his main thing
he didn't want to expose it because he
learned from fighting ebony ma in new
york that the moment he tried to
open the aya vagamoto up he reached for
it he grabbed it
so he's thinking about a guy who has
four infinity stones he's gonna be able
to
counteract any of my spells so i don't
want to expose it he hid it amongst the
stars in the background like that uh
temple of doom assassin you know it's
just kind of blended in the whole time
and then
[Music]
i can't believe i'm going so why didn't
he help stark spoons well stark's wounds
weren't
fatal right they were they're pretty bad
but stark had that miracle goo that he
just sprayed on and he walked it off he
was fine strange knew that he'd be okay
so why would he use the time stone now
for that he only
brought it out when he had to surrender
it you know because he knew at that
point that
thanos four stones were insurmountable
and yes you could say that you know
right before he dusted he said this is
the only way but that is the plan
defense and we are not using it sir
you're out of order i don't i
show you how to order he had other
reasons that last points
it resonates with me because if there's
really any character
in the mcu qualified to make a snap
judgment on whether or not a wound is
mortal
it's probably a celebrated surgeon right
like that right he could probably
if anyone's gonna have to guess just
from a visual like he could recover from
those wounds
uh strange is going to have the data in
his brain so that that that holds water
for me but we'll see
we'll see this trial moves on so follow
up
why didn't strange use more of his
spells against 2014
thanos end game when thanos had no
infinity stones to fight back with in
that iteration
okay so this is all right you're
needling me here all right yeah
you're right 2014 in that final battle
didn't have any infinity stones
until he got his hands on the gauntlet
so presumably strange could have used
all the moves that he put on thanos
infinity war
the mirror dimension the images of icon
where he makes duplicates of himself
crimson bands of sidorak all that stuff
he could have sent him on a multiverse
trip as concept art would have shown him
uh doing
2014 thanos if any of that happened to
him yeah he would have been confused
he would have been like what the hell is
this i have no way to fight back
but i will still say my client is
innocent of negligence here because
rewind back to that battle strange spent
most of that battle
keeping them all from drowning since
that lake water was spilling into the
blast crater
he had his hands full this whole battle
he had his hands fall
the club doesn't fit
[Music]
anything you say strange should have
done yeah
fog of war fog of war okay
i like your character your comic con
2021 character will be johnny cockfell
which is a combination of johnny cochran
and jerry seinfeld
yeah it's gonna be very hard for you to
pull off but if anyone can do it it's
you
all right fair enough fair enough i like
you know you come with the facts
and we appreciate that this is a court
of logic and reason so
you bring facts to me i respond to them
whether i understand them or not
all right our next charge as levied by
pozzi
on discord why didn't strange use his
sling ring portals more often
he could have sliced off thanos arm with
a portal or he could have portaled them
all back home from the q ship
okay a fair question your honor
sorcerers are well aware of the
weaponization of portals we saw wong
slicing off
obsidian's arm earlier in infinity war
uh and strange definitely weaponized
portals against caicilia c
also used to [ __ ] around with thor and
loki plenty in ragnarok
uh he himself returned from mount
everest with the portal so why wouldn't
he
again use it to escape another
near-death moment
in infinity war well this one's a bit
tougher
but i will defer to my expert witness
i am a expert witness joe russo
co-director of the film imagine him
swinging open these doors strutting down
that aisle
the gallery's just like oh yeah oh my
goodness brother anthony starts to talk
and he's like
just going i'm the one who's actually
doing all the work here uh
and then uh he says quote
thanos's skin is almost impenetrable
we don't know whether doctor strange had
the capability to
do it to cut off the arm if he failed to
cut it on time
thanos would still be able to do the
snap doctor strange he says realize this
issue during his millions of test runs
okay so
now joe russo's trying to use the
planned defense uh we will not be
relying on the plane defense so
basically
the reason is because thanos's skin was
too thick
like all parts oh we knew that yeah we
knew that we did that
but really this is like the same kind of
argument he has infinity stones he
controls space he controls reality so
any kind of spells that are there he's
got a couple different ways he can
counteract it and see it kind of coming
uh and the moment it starts to happen it
can because those sling rings they
aren't immediate right there's like
a couple sparks begin and he got maybe
like four seconds of wind-up time
so at that point he could just be like
shoo shoo and then use an extinguishing
spell to put out the sparks
and then he's fine and then he snaps
your neck so uh
why not portal home i would argue an
infinity war that strange had never been
that far off world now he had been in
the dark dimension but he didn't get
there
with portal and doctor strange he just
it was already that gateway had already
been opened he just kind of soared up
into it
and he soared back so this guy is in an
unfamiliar situation but really the big
reason why he stranged in portal home in
infinity war is
stark had won him over in the debate
strange wanted to turn the ship around
he wanted to go back
but tony convinced him that they need to
take the fight to
thanos so that point he's like okay well
i'm not gonna go back i'm not gonna
retreat from this fight because i'd
rather
take it to his home turf than back to
new york and hurt more countless people
so uh he knew that that uh infinity
stone was like a magnet so he wanted to
make sure the magnet had
you know drawed all the trouble
somewhere else i would also say that
um by taking the fight to titan they
would face thanos alone without his army
and if you watch that battle on titan i
don't i wouldn't say thanos is so
interested in killing them yes he does
do a lot of attacks too that would kill
them
but like unlike you know the rest of the
black order
in the outrider army back in wakanda
they were savage they were ready to
kill people and i don't think strange
wanted that situation you'd rather
fight you know six on one or whatever
that was okay
well eric you've done something you've
led that was
but you did something that you
gonna lead you straight to the heart of
this judge and implying that
dr strange's character evolved and
learned things from his own standalone
movie that he applied into a further
avengers sequel are you saying character
development crossing
mcu movies he learned his own arrogance
can't always be the only way to solving
problems that sometimes he must go
against
what he thinks is right and listen to
someone that may actually have a better
idea than him and go along with a plan
someone like tony stark the antithesis
of who stephen strange is even though
maybe they're more similar than they'd
like to admit
thus leading him to the actual correct
solution even though it goes against
everything he as a person who thinks
he's the smartest person on earth
would normally do because he's learned
by failing and by experiencing life
wow i don't know eric you just moved me
there this court
this court just got two degrees warmer
and my heart just got three sizes bigger
and i'm getting a little light-headed
and my left arm is tingling
is there a doctor in the courtroom can
the defendant uh check up on our judge
to make sure
anthony russo tries to speak up against
shut up was there a bigger missed
opportunity than an end game for the
russo brothers for the brothers part to
just disappear and
say the russo and then like a smiling
russo brother
anthony russo's kids have gotten more
screen time in the mcu than he has
that's a good point
all right so next russell mc one of my
favorite rappers on discord says
why didn't strange try to trap thanos in
the mirror dimension more
you bring up a good point that the mere
dimension exists purely to keep enemies
in a separate reality where their
attacks won't damage
the real world uh kind of like a bouncy
castle
uh for the bully kid you have to stay
the bouncy castle and the rest of the
kids
will play on the jungle gym um and
strange is well aware of this but
uh sorry my friend strange did try to do
this
during the wizard duel strange did fire
a mirror dimension spell
at thanos it was very quick a lot of
people missed it but
but he tried but thanos immediately
deflected it and he turned into a
black hole and threw it back at him and
strange is probably just like
i'm not going to try that again uh so i
think at that moment strange very
quickly learned that most of his spells
would probably be useless against the
four infinity stones that thanos had
already acquired and would not try again
to trap him in the mirror dimension
yes i'm picking up a theme on these and
that is that we are dealing with a
hyper-intelligent
superhero that also has the has had the
power to manipulate time
yeah so he's lived thousands of
lifetimes in his one lifetime so
a lot of this is chalked up to he's just
been there before
and done that before so he's not gonna
make the same mistake twice because he
is in fact
brilliant all right next question next
charge
[Music]
alone one pant or unpant alone
no pants asks why didn't strange look
into the future more often
all right this one's a very fair
question because strange
should have looked in the future long
before getting to the titan
uh in fact he learned from the ancient
one that it's totally okay for sorcerer
supreme to just like look in the future
as
much as you want but he also might have
learned a lesson from the ancient one to
not do that because
uh the reason why i think this charge
doesn't stick the ancient one warned him
that when she looked at strange's future
she saw
limitless possibilities so at that point
strange probably figured it was a futile
exercise
to see his own future it was only when
he had a specific task at hand
thwarting thanos on titan that he was
able to
focus his forward glances on one set of
possible actions as opposed to just like
i want to see my future what's my future
and he throw the whole deck of cards in
the air
he was able to be like i want to see my
future but just
in hearts and then you just flip over
the hearts that's what he did there does
that make sense
i don't think my metaphor made sense
listen i'm a fan of close-up magic so
anytime you bring up throwing a deck of
cards in the air
all i bring it back to is it turns into
a dove and flies away
is that enough of a reference for you
that's what happened there yep you're
the jimmy wu of uh
of our side of the mcu i am jimmy wu of
mcu that's what they call me don't tweet
it
anyway uh follow up why didn't strange
destroy the mind stone instead he left
it up to shuri
wanda and the others to scramble and
then fail to do it
before thanos could arrive huh okay well
i'm sorry my client did not have the
capability to destroy an infinity stone
they clearly state that only one the
maxwell could do it because her powers
were derived from the mind stone
presumably carol danvers might have been
able to since her powers were
technically derived from the space stone
from that lightspeed engine
i would say it is fair for my client
steven strange to assume that the mind
stone was safe in vision's forehead
especially with the time stone moved to
another planet as he was doing at the
start of infinity war
the problem really with the mine stone
is it was cap's fault cap and the other
avengers
insisted on saving vision's life in this
removal process
they could have just destroyed it
immediately that's what vision wanted to
do he's like my character sucks so bad
please kill me off in the midpoint of
this movie uh
he begged him he begged him he's like
i'm done i'm tired of putting on this
red makeup and every movie i loved it
when i was jarvis and i could just go
into an adr booth for one afternoon
and then take my feet and leave instead
i have to wear this stupid
uh fishy hat
this stupid swimming cap and and get
spray-painted
red while everyone else gets to sip my
ties and show up for a day to shoot
their seeds
one and done robert downey jr they call
him one take tony
and for me i gotta do these takes over
and over again
in this blazing georgia heat are you
kidding me kill me
please kill me and they didn't do it and
that is on
cap that is on cap saying we don't trade
lives and visions like
uh so i believe that strange as you said
this guy knows how to call it he knows
how to see a dead on a rival situation
better than anyone i believe he would
have concurred if he was in the room yes
he did take a hippocratic oath to do no
harm
but vision is not a living
person he is a robot with no soul uh
and i believe strange would have been
like ah hypocritical doesn't apply here
kill him yes and at this point the
audience the gallery
bursts into a pause and i scream order
corner i'll throw you all out of here
and then i walk out already triumphant
i've already won them
sweet symphonies playing in the
background
i can't say anymore next why didn't
strange tell stark or the others more of
the details of his future [ __ ]
uh this might be fair to ask strange did
kind of play coy
with tony infinity ward in game he's
like here's what's gonna happen but i'm
not gonna tell you all the detail
like he could give tony a bit of a clue
of what he needed to do he's like
maybe next time you'll have a better
chance or if we could only
turn back time instead he kind of
applied that dump back to the future
logic
you know in which knowledge of future
events creates like a paradox in which
it won't happen
it's like don't think about elephants
and you think about it and then
your your own grandpa's your lover now
um
but yeah i've been there and then yeah
yeah yeah but i would
the problem with this is like scott lang
said an endgame back to the future is a
bunch of [ __ ] like the movie is
saying back to the future doesn't apply
but strange kind of used back to the
future
reasoning there so back to the future is
a bunch of [ __ ]
i don't know why everyone believes that
but that isn't true but i would still
say
my client steven strange is innocent
because tony's eureka moment of
discovering time travel only occurred
after he gave up trying
and then he was given an opportunity to
pick it back up after seeing that photo
of peter parker who was holding his
diploma inverted
giving tony the idea of an inverted
mobius strip
so i i think strange new tony stark he's
the kind of guy who needs all of his
ideas to be his own ideas he can't be
told what to do
he needs to even if it takes five years
figure out time travel on his own and
figure out that time travel is a
solution on his own and
he knows that tony is is kind of selfish
maybe and
if if tony knew in advance that he would
have to make the sacrifice play he might
have tried to
come with a shortcut that didn't require
a sacrifice maybe put roadie in iron man
soon
boom you looking for this
i will admit that my client does break
his hippocratic oath by letting tony
stark die
well uh pretty damning stuff right there
i i do think yeah look there's a fair
amount of i think
the alpha male nature of doctor strange
and
tony stark led to this probably being
more difficult than if it had been like
cap and doctor strange cap would have
been eager to please
the cap's a dumb dumb he's just like
jump on the grenade he's like done i'm
already on it
i love it it's already it's inside of me
now all right so
let's let's bring this home uh with our
final charge why didn't doctor strange
permanently prevent the threat from
dormammu with something more than the
time stone
all right this one's a tough one to
argue because by using just the time
stone to thwart dormammu
he did make the time stone the one
nuclear deterrent
from dormammu attacking us in the future
and now that the time stone is
removed uh dormammu could just simply
attack our reality again and we would be
screwed but uh my defense here your
honor
is that he doesn't necessarily know the
time stone
inside the eye of agamotto was the thing
that powered that time loop that trapped
him for all he knows he was just that
magic necklace not the
stone inside it that that uh mess with
his head
he doesn't understand time you know it
was like a weapon that was completely
foreign to him because he's completely
outside of time
he was bewildered by this time lube
strange victory over him
was really more of just like a symbolic
hey don't [ __ ] with us
kind of victory so as long as no one
tells dormammu
that the time stone is gone we we should
be fine
it should be fine as long as it remains
a secret
yes okay bruce lip sync realities your
honor may i make a closing statement
just to tip you one way or the other
yes absolutely okay very quickly i would
say
my client dr steven strange celebrated
md he's got lots of awards lots of words
the best awards the most beautiful
awards the hugest awards
we will not be using the simple plan
defense although that should be
enough we should take him at his word
but my client dr stephen strange is a
god who works in mysterious ways
who are we to question him he's right to
be timid about his use of the time
stone especially when that is the thing
his enemy most wanted to get his hands
on
could he have used portals smarter sure
could he have been more forthcoming with
tony stark
maybe but he also might have been glad
to see tony stark die
it's time for someone else to take over
the mcu as the smartest one his days of
being an oath bound position
ended when his hands ended sorcerers
adhere to rules that we
cannot comprehend and we are best not
questioning them and trusting them
to protect our reality douchebag
quack quack quack quack
quack quack
i wish derrick god why did production
have to shut down we'd be perfect for
the reboot of mighty ducks it'd be great
bash brothers right here the new bash
brothers
tb and eric v smashing them bashing them
crying to their moms after the game all
right time for my verdict now
now i can give a verdict that compassion
speech had already swung me towards the
decision i was gonna make of course
dr strange is innocent of course a
patient
learned man who has changed the
intellect of a doctor the powers of a
sorcerer
he's not making any wrong moves there
are no wasted movements it's all bruce
lee level karate
it's magnificent you do not waste
dr strange's time because he alone
understands
how much time he's already wasted i am
wasting time
now explaining my decision that would
discuss
doctor strange okay he's innocent he did
his best he did what had to be done
is there some gray areas with the
hippocratic oath sure there is but any
good doctor messes with the oath all
right
you want a doctor that's willing to
break the rules but also
play by him so religiously that it
causes the death of beloved movie stars
making 50 million dollars a movie that
their removal from the franchise opens
up new possibilities of both visual
effects
and the casting of new stars i find him
innocent and you know what i find you
guilty of doing a great job
but that's still a punishable offense on
youtube so you're going away
and you're you're sentenced to j you
said this to 50 years
i'd take a prison over this blue dungeon
at least they have oxygen
good point all right we're going to move
on to some people who helped us make
this episode thank you to our friends at
audible for sponsoring this episode
we want you to listen to the new audible
original the sandman
based on the best-selling dc graphic
novels written by the great
neil gaiman which were hailed by the los
angeles times magazine as
the greatest epic in the history of
comic books and
you know they're onto something for sure
this audio adaptation is decades in the
making it stars professor x himself
james mcavoy in the title role follow
morpheus the dreamlord as he's pulled
from the dream realm and imprisoned on
earth but when he finally escapes he
must restore his power
to rebuild his dominion and that is just
the beginning of it
it features a powerhouse ensemble cast
including riz ahmed kat dennings michael
sheen
and more in your wildest dreams you have
never heard
anything like this listen now only on
audible
go to audible.com the sandman
yes oh i love that love that
all right now big question is going to
move on to some bite size questions that
our man
tommy beck told we'll answer are you
ready tommy fire my way
adrian 2k18 on discord asks how strong
is spider-man's webbing oh adrian i'm so
glad that you asked you wouldn't by any
chance be adrian
toombs would you i don't even understand
the reference oh
this isn't some treacherous effort by
the vulture
to find this information out no we're on
to you i have no idea what you're
talking about let's talk about his
strength the web line's tensile strength
remember tensile strength
is the amount of force required to pull
a material until it breaks
bam with that web uh has been estimated
based on i think the weight of objects
that he's picked up
in movies and in comics to be about 120
pounds
per square millimeter of cross-section
in the weapon however in the movies and
in the tv
and in video games we see superheroes
and villains
all the time breaking the webbing with
ease uh and
in the ultimate spider-man cartoon like
eight years ago that rock the leaper
a non-powered villain breaks it
literally with no effort yeah yeah and
adrian tombs like
cuts it as well like in homecoming so
spider-man's webbing does have
immense tensile strength but it appears
to be weaker in other areas like sheer
strength and durability so in theory it
just depends on how the webbing is
applied and
and what kind of force the the the
different type of webs
can apply to it so spider-man he can
fire his webbing and i think the globs
he could also do
the web grenades he can do like ricochet
webb he can do sprays
he can shoot like a little glove spray
into someone's face
okay
[Music]
so obviously if he if he's firing any
continuous ropes it's going to be
stronger you know if he's fighting in
traditional webbing but if he uses
little globs or sprays of it
you know to get in people's eyes or the
web grenades those are going to be
a little bit weaker and probably easier
to break so pretty much the answer to
this is like
any power for a good superhero his webs
are exactly as strong as they need to be
for whatever store we are reading so it
basically is like
if they need to be strong enough to lift
up a bus that's how strong they are
if they need to be weak enough for a
little girl to break it as a joke no
offense women can do everything rewind
that john take that out
if they need to have a tiny kid break it
to show
a brute strength you know that if
they're so light a kid can do it for a
funny moment in the comic that'll be how
strong they are then so it's tough to
say but
but they're they're obviously in in
terms of tensile strength and in terms
of swinging things
they're incredibly powerful and of
course the the webbing dissolves after a
couple hours like it's
supposed to be the case so that way he
doesn't cover the whole city and his
freaking webbing that everyone sticks to
but i love that uh detail and the
amazing spider-man 2 with andrew
garfield how he
sprays the little web on the kid's
science project and i imagine that kid
like because the tensile strength is so
strong he can't adjust it and he's like
he did it wrong
in five minutes and then eventually he
goes up in front of the classroom and
the whole thing just melts
and then he becomes a villain and then
that's origin
[Music]
next question a jaisal or ajsol on
discord asks why doesn't hella use the
tesseract to travel
this is kind of a understanding of the
tesseract
as it is as an object in the mcu and
that is
the people who see the tesseract don't
inherently
know how to use it it needs to be
modified by science loki only really
ever learns how to use the tesseract
effectively when he employs scientists
to build a mechanism around
to make it work so when she first sees
it she's intrigued by it but she uses
the mode of transportation
that most as guardians use it uses the
bifrost
because she doesn't know what powers the
tesseract has i mean even
the other people have interacted with in
the mcu red skull basically touched it
and that was the end of it like it was
like you know they don't necessarily
know
they don't know how to harness the power
of the tesseract
hella is presented to us as a warrior
not as like a supremely intellectual or
scientific being so it stands to reason
she just didn't know it had that power
or she just didn't have
she didn't have the way to harness it in
that but she didn't she didn't have
the time with it that loki had to you
know go undercover and pose as a
scientist in a research laboratory to
get
the machine built around it so i think
it just boils down to
knowing what you have when you have it
like any good relationship you don't
know what you got till it's gone
i guess it is kind of tough because loki
did just freaking pick it up an end game
and
seemed to know exactly where he was
going when he portaled out of there
whereas that's a fair point that's a
fair point but like uh
maybe loki's trials throughout the
avengers final act
taught him like oh i actually figured
this thing out whereas
hella has never really been around this
tesseract and
maybe still fears it our last question
monster man alex on discord asks
can mr fantastic's elastic body ever be
broken
and we hope monster man isn't a real
monster
who's trying to break a reed richards in
half
monster man monster man monster mid
monster men get in my office
monster men give me your gun and badge
you're off the force monster man
that kid jumped in front of the bullet
chief monster man
i don't know why you announce yourself
like that that makes it
worse mr fantastic he can extend his
limbs torso neck
other things if you know what i'm saying
ladies i never sue storm never looks
angry that's what i'm saying
she does frequently look exhausted all
right to a great distance the maximum
length he can kind of extend out to
before he
identifies as it becoming uncomfortable
is about three or four blocks or 1500
feet
he has said that in comics that like if
it goes beyond 1500 feet
if the pain becomes too much for him so
hypothetically if you had like
thor and hercules running in opposite
directions
once it got beyond 1500 feet he would be
in extreme pain i don't know that it
would
break because we know wolverine has
tried
albeit under mind control to slice him
his skin just
forms around the blades it just molds
around wolverine's blades so wolverine's
adamantium flaws
are not powerful enough to slice him so
it's really unknown if he could
truly be broken but he can be stretched
to such excruciating pain that he would
be
useless in his powers so can he be
incapacitated
yes can he be broken it does not appear
so yeah that's a good point like
i think you would need a real out of the
box solution to it
right like we know at the start of the
secret invasion event
uh hank pym used that d m d
molecularization process to like
destabilize his body but even then he
bounced back
eventually so there are other ways you
can do it but you can't just take the
traditional route of like let's just
keep stretching and see how far he goes
all right thank you for answering those
questions tommy very interesting
all those but now we have time for one
final box scraps
question box of scraps blocks of scraps
oh miss pot i wish she left
i would have preferred she lived
[Laughter]
jeff bridges is from malibu california
not the wild west as you would assume
all right anyway fox's box of squirrels
all right our question this week what's
the worst roommate experience you've
ever had ah
all right i want to preface this i've
had a lot of roommates uh we live in los
angeles roommates
are part of that lifestyle this person
is by no means the worst roommate
i've ever had he's my friend to this day
i will not say his name out loud
eric you know him he is a very very very
nice person
this story is just too hilarious not to
tell because it is such an
inconsiderate behavior by him that led
to a hilarious
situation and he was very young at this
point so i'm going to give him the
benefit of the doubt
that he's evolved since then anyway let
me set the stage i worked at a high-end
bakery lunch counter restaurant
in the larchmont area of los angeles
which is a very upscale
and affluent neighborhood where we had
sandwiches salads cookies all this great
stuff but it was quicker service so we
had
a lot of people in the industry coming
in and out anyway at the end of the day
because all of us
are you know want to be actors who are
broke the uh the kindness in our hearts
the owners would divvy up the food that
was left over because it was all fresh
and like
you couldn't really reuse stuff so we
would get boxes and bags of cookies and
stuff like that so i would bring it home
to my
living situation which at that point
about nine years ago
i was living in a house with four four
other comedians in the front of the
house
and then two comedians in the back house
so there were seven of us so i would
come home and basically it was like
something out of like
like all of her like i would be like all
right gang food's here
you're the artful dodger shut up and
drink your chin
yeah and like you know my only rule was
like i i really honestly felt this way
was like
everybody can eat whatever they want
please just don't eat the last
of one thing because if i tried to put
limitations on like
don't eat this or don't eat this i felt
like that would make people too
uncomfortable and i didn't want it all
for myself like it was too much food
so i was like just don't eat the last
thing well this roommate
was completely uh ignored that rule they
ate
all the food indeterminately whatever
they want i once made
um italian sausage on the grill and
brought them inside
on a plate went and ran to the bathroom
to go to the bathroom came back and he
had eaten
two of them these were just grilled and
he said oh i thought they were for the
house
and i was like you thought i just made
house italian sauce
you know what that's fine he's like uh
the pie is
wafting its scent on the windowsill and
he floats over to the uh
to the sausages and gobbles them up so
cut to
an evening much like this evening uh
nine years ago where i get a frantic
phone call from this person saying
i'm dying i'm having a heart attack
i am i i don't know what's going on with
me
i'm dying i'm dying and i'm like well
what's going on and he's like
i i think i'm having a heart attack i'm
waiting for an ambulance to come this is
a healthy
22 year old person i'm like what would
you need me to cut
to come get you he's like no i'm going
to the hospital and then i'm flying home
to be with my family if once i get
released from the hospital
so this person had this incident and i'm
like this is very strange for this
person to have had
a heart attack well we take inventory of
what's missing from the house and all
the cookies are gone but
in eating all of my baked goods that i
brought home he also ate the only other
baked good
in our refrigerator which happened to be
a 300 milligram edible marijuana cookie
that my other roommate had thinking it
was one of my
fresh baked delights and thus infusing
himself with enough
thc to become a family 100
milligrams so his heart attack was just
a high
literally no pun intended uh level
anxiety attack from
you know being high on weed without
knowing that you're hot yeah if you
didn't know
so this poor guy thought he had a heart
attack and then at the hospital they
were like nothing's wrong with you
and then he literally did fly home to
phoenix
yeah on the power of his seemingly uh
devastating heart attack he fluttered
through the sky so yeah so we figured
out the reason that he
had this incident was because he
disobeyed the dodie the last cookie rule
and ate the last cookie which was a weed
cookie although i love this man very
much and if he ever watches this he'll
know this is about him but he has plenty
of embarrassing stories about me he can
come and tell on another
platform all right that was that was
pretty bad that was a pretty bad one
what do you got
oh wow i i do know this guy and we
probably love him even more now for
for this happening happened to a point i
mean it really is kind of an adorable
when you think about
the fact that i was young which made him
super young i mean he may have been
barely 21 at that point oh wow yeah
um i like you have had um many many
roommates
i've been lucky that most of them have
been great i i
i don't have a whole lot of horror
stories but in college
i was in a similar situation everyone in
our college improv club for like a year
lived in this we wanted our own frat
house and i was
too much of a wuss to sign my name on
the lease for the start of it i i had
another living situation like i'll just
hang out over there
but like eight other people lived in
this house that was meant for six people
people crashing on couches it was a mess
we called it the tsf house
uh we wanted our like lambda lambda
lambda
it was uh gross um but it wasn't just
all dudes there was it was like half
women half men and the women are just
like i gotta get out of here this place
is disgusting
so like over the course of the year-long
lease i think a total of 14 different
people lived there
and then my final summer before i moved
out to los angeles after i had graduated
there was like two months
left i was like i need a place to crash
i'll live in the tsf house because one
of the people on the lease is like
i'm already paid through you can just
like stay there for free and i'm like
yes
big big mistake because at that point in
the summer
like half the people who live there
they're paying like 200 a month in rent
dirt cheap rent and they didn't want to
spend any extra money so they would
never turn on the ac
and it just got oh no and gross
trash everywhere and then 14 people's
worth of crap had just been left there
you know there's like those sociological
experiments where it's like the
diffusion of responsibility
where they'll get one person one like
kid to scream help help help in a
crowded place and if there's like
a ton of people around no one will help
the kid but if there's one person around
they'll be like well it's on me
they'll go help the kids right it was
kind of like you know 14 people it's
just like oh someone else will clean
this up or someone else needs this
pot and pan set so i'll just leave it
there and i'll move out and i'll come
get it
when it comes time to clear out no one
did everyone
had all moved on and it came time for
like the end of our lease
and everyone who had been there
originally when the lease was signed was
like well we expect to get our security
deposit back and those of us who were
there were like
[ __ ] no we're not gonna like clean up
this place there's
it's it looks like hoarders by the end
of the time of us living there
but still we had intended to do some
clean at least clean out the fridge and
we like waited the last week and then my
buddy ricky
god bless them just like piled [ __ ] into
garbage bags that just line the hallways
that final week because he was still
trying to get us to he was original
signee
and then the morning of we had and to
try to wake up at 7 a.m to clean up the
place
and the electricity got shut off the day
because it was the last day whoever paid
the electricity bill
had it uh shut off that morning so our
alarms didn't go off we woke up hot and
sticky
because the ac wasn't on and our fans
weren't on so we woke up at like 10 a.m
just being
in a pool of sweat being like oh no but
ricky had worked the whole night
and tommy was terrifying i walked in the
kitchen i heard
i heard him scrubbing scrub a scrub of
scrub scrubbing oh god
and i'm like what is going on and then i
look at him he is
just out of his mind just like sleep
deprived
[Music]
he doesn't even notice being a ghost
like face shifting through me
walks to the bathroom rings out a rag
in the toilet water rings it out goes
back
and scrubs out the fridge and he goes
they turned off the power
ain't got no water and just scrub
the scrub and scrub the refrigerator and
i'm like ricky no and i was like ricky
it's not worth it he's like i need to
finish
i was like ricky it's not worth it and
then philip was one of the original
signees and he called me he's like
what's the problem
and i'm like not now philip if you want
your
if you want your deposit back you got to
get here and do it yourself
and he's like what are you talking about
and i took a picture of what the place
looked like and he's like how much could
there be
and then he's like i understand after i
sent him the picture he's like
just leave it just leave it and we all
just left our keys
and we got out of there it was a
nightmare
uh and i felt no one got their deposit i
believe the
the landlord just like paid guys to to
just junk at all
he probably burned down the place
because we had so many
parties there it was everything was
covered in beer stains
oh god yeah those old college houses are
like your campus are like yeah
they're like condemned like the only
people who would live there
are other college kids that are like
this is great this looks lived in
yeah so we were the bad roommates in
that today it was it was like a murder
on the orient express there wasn't one
culprit it was everyone was the culprit
everyone had guilt
the real bad guy in that in that story
is society
society made you that way that's right i
don't take in responsibility that i was
made no
no i was made into a victim
you're the bad guy well that's our show
uh tommy as always
so great to chat with you learn a little
bit about your life
and we were able to exonerate dr strange
which at the end of the day happy to do
it we just need another rich white man
to walk free
the justice system works uh reminder
that you can all join us on our official
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars you can get an
audio version of the show by subscribing
to new rockstars big question wherever
you get your podcasts
and you can send us your big questions
on twitter using the hashtag
bigquestion follow me at eavos follow
tommy
tommy bechtold follow new rockstars and
social subscribe here on youtube to get
too much information on all the
stuff you're afraid to ask about let's
go uh have a nice steak dinner like all
the attorneys
do steak cigars and whiskeys to
celebrate our victory
to musso and frank oh it's still shut
down take out musso and frank
styrofoam containers of mussels and
olive oil or whatever
old-fashioned uh in a nice styrofoam cup
[Laughter]
it's one way to do it all right goodbye
everyone
[Music]
you